it's Asia's largest air show but it
doesn't seem like it more than 70
companies have pulled out including big
names like us defense company Lockheed
Martin all because of concerns over the
spread of corona virus we do see hope
they see more picked up over the next
few days but I we presumably was going
to be staying about 50% time so far
people coming into visiting the show
Singapore has the third largest number
of confirmed cases after China and a
cruise ship quarantined in Japan some
countries have advised their citizens
against unnecessary travel to the
city-state but organizers are determined
to put on a good show even giving
special exemption from a ban on visitors
from China to the country's military
aerobatic team seen performing here
fears over coronavirus are not just
affecting attendance at the event but
also raising concerns over demand for
aviation companies and services it's a
major impact it's a crisis for the
industry we've had experience before
SARS almost 20 years ago was a similarly
a devastating impact but there was a
very strong recovery so we have to
manage the current situation get through
it and as when the recovery comes be
ready to respond to that dozens of
airlines have suspended flights to and
from China the outbreak of coronavirus
comes as the aviation industry is
already experiencing slower growth air
passenger demand grew at a smaller pace
last year compared to 2018 and it was
also the worst year for air cargo since
the end of a global financial crisis in
2009 a former chief executive for a
low-cost airline says companies
especially those exposed to Chinese
markets will suffer in the short term in
this case we don't know when the endless
when you don't know the end it's really
really quite tough to be honest and
what's going to happen is that you have
to refund back the money that people
already paid for plus the future booking
is going to be slimming down many
analysts say long-term growth prospects
for the aviation industry remain
positive but the number of confirmed
cases and deaths from coronavirus has
already surpassed that of the SARS
outbreak in 2003 and what's more
difficult to predict is how long this
outbreak will last and what impact it
will have on the industry florence lui
al jazeera Singapore